[主播] 吃到东方甄选所选的这一款玉米，我相信你会如我一样呢，回忆起童年。
[主播] 回忆起那些无忧无虑背着书包回到家里头，招急忙慌的，书包扔在凳子上，一溜烟跑到巷子里，跑了一整个下午。
[主播] 没有那么多的作业要写，也没有那么多的人情需要照顾，没有那么多的烦心事要处理，也没有那么多的痛苦要焦虑。
[主播] 你玩了一整晚回来，有时候妈妈看你玩得太累了，把你喊回来，锅里煮出了自己家地里摘出来的玉米。
[主播] 香气扑鼻，你用筷子戳着，拿在手上，边啃边跑。
[主播] 你跑的时候，背后的阳光温暖，洋洋洒洒落在地上。
[主播] 它在你面前投下了跟你一样大小的影子，你边跑边追。
[主播] 嘴里头那一口玉米，淡淡的回甘味，扑鼻的香。
[主播] 好多年后你到现在都记得，你甚至还记得在仲夏夜的风里，你们坐在院子里乘凉，夜风袭来，树叶沙沙作响。
[主播] 天空偶尔飞过一两只不知名的鸟，发出清脆的叫声。
[主播] 你一个手里拿着筷子戳着的玉米棒子在啃，一个手里还贪心的抱着水井里刚取出来冰镇的西瓜。
[主播] 大人们在忙着说他们的事情，有时候低声细语，有时候开怀大笑。
[主播] 你不管心，那个时候人间的事情你还没有经历，你无忧无虑的像个孩子。
[主播] Young and carefree. 无忧无虑，以正年轻。
[主播] 所以如果我们说要找到美食的话，美食的背后一定是情感的连接。Young and carefree. Free就是没有，care就是担心，没有担心，所以无忧无虑，年轻且无忧无虑。
[主播] 好多年后你回忆起来，其实那个玉米的味道记不太清楚了，尝着好像很像。
[主播] 但你清楚记得是那些仲夏的夜里头，繁星点缀，树叶沙沙作响，微风吹过。
[主播] 你年轻，那时候你头也不疼，颈椎也不疼，也不会在睡醒失眠的夜里头辗转反侧，也不会在睡醒的早晨感觉头昏脑胀。
[主播] 那时候你爸妈身体还很健康，他们年轻，平安喜乐，爷爷奶奶也陪在你身边。
[主播] 你其实不是想玉米，你是想当年的自己啊。
[主播] 我感觉到这个玉米还是挺让我回忆过去的。我是一个念旧的人，我是一个这个容易容易敏感的人。
[主播] 所以也正因为敏感，才能够从生活中捕捉到很多原本你们所忽略的细节。
[主播] 那些细节其实更让人贴心，更让人安心，更让人暖心，也最让人放心。
[主播] 那就是人间烟火呀。
[主播] 又下着啊，这句牌。
[嘉宾] 没事。
[嘉宾] 当你老了，走不动了，炉火旁打盹，回忆青春。
[嘉宾] 多少人曾爱你青春的诗歌，爱慕你的美丽，加一或真心。不止有一个人，还爱你青春的灵魂，爱你苍老的脸上的皱纹。
[嘉宾] 当你老了，我只希望这首歌是唱给你的。
[嘉宾] 谢谢大家。
[主播] 谢谢大家。欢迎七七。
[嘉宾] 哎呀。
[主播] 中关村兵马俑要去吃饭了。
[嘉宾] 你今天还上吗？
[主播] 我应该晚上还有一场。
[嘉宾] 晚上还有一场，所以说喜欢董宇辉啊，董宇辉。中关村周杰伦，喜欢中关村周杰伦的朋友们，咱们今天的话他还有一场是在晚上应该是。对，所以说可以持续关注咱们直播间啊，我们是由俞敏洪俞老师领队，新东方老师给大家去甄选好物平台，我们叫做东方甄选。So if you're new to this live stream, please don't go away and please click this follow button over here and join this big family. 如果您今天是第一天来到咱们直播间，不要走开，喜欢我们的话，左上角给咱们来一波关注啊，我们说换主播的时候再提醒大家，今天咱们董老师啊，也叫方老师，或者叫咱们的这个铁盘王子是不是？这个中关村周杰伦，他今天晚上还有一场哟，大家可以持续关注一下。